Do you know what my people call
this past year the long halloween
the holiday killer's covering his tracks
i'm here to cut a deal you want falcone and
i got plenty on him heads i'll take it your
father went into business with the roman and how
many innocent lives did he end up trading for it
where'd you find them you're not going to like it
when you were coming up you
wouldn't have thought to hire freaks
times change it's hard to believe the
man who stood on this roof and made
that promise would cross the line
everyone's invited to this party
twinkle twinkle little bat
how i wonder what you're
what is this judgment day
Welcome back everyone this is going to be
my new batman trailer video for the long
halloween movie they're releasing later this
year it's actually going to be two parts so
technically it's two movies but if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos there is a lot of batman
related movie stuff happening in the next year
also explain what's going on with that brand new
batman series that they just announced yesterday
we have this movie coming then we have the matt
reeves batman movie with robert pattinson then
we have ben affleck's batman and michael keaton
batman coming back in the flash movie next year
the long halloween part 1 is coming out june 22nd
part 2 is being released july 27th and supposedly
when they release part 2 they're also going to be
releasing a trailer for the new injustice movie
that they're making even though the justice league
snyder cut felt kind of like an injustice movie
they actually made a legit animated injustice gods
among us movie that they'll be releasing sometime
next year i'm assuming but if you couldn't tell
from the voice it's jensen ackles himself playing
batman finally he's actually been cosplaying to
so many batman characters for so many years he
finally got to play batman he played a version of
red hood in the animated under the red hood movie
but in real life steven ml actually said he
campaigned a few years ago to get jensen to be the
aeroverse version of batman even though they kind
of imply that there is a version of batman and
the arrowverse somewhere we've never actually seen
him on screen even though they did do a version of
hush so technically hush should look like batman
they have these weird rules when it comes to doing
batman on tv but some of the matt reeves batman
movie with robert pattinson is actually inspired
by the story of the long halloween they're not
doing a copy paste version of the story so it
won't be the story of the long halloween there'll
just be elements from the long halloween story
that inspires some of the stuff that's going on
during the batman movie the long halloween is
this big murder mystery story with batman gordon
and harvey dent for most of the story running
around gotham trying to chase down the serial
killer that they call the holiday killer because
they keep killing members of the mob on different
holidays of the year the batman movie is this big
murder mystery that batman is trying to solve in
unravel and it turns into this much larger mystery
like in the trailer you hear his voiceover where
he's saying how am i connected to all this and
the riddler implies you'll find out soon enough
it seems like the riddler is trying to take down
this corrupt mayor and all this other corruption
in gotham city and he's trying to incite batman
to action there are similar things going on in
the long halloween but not the exact same thing
where you have a character who's trying to do good
things ultimately but just doing it in completely
the wrong way by going around killing a bunch of
people the movie is changing some of the events of
the long halloween they're not speed running the
plot completely but even though they're doing this
is a two-part movie there are a couple things
that they're not going to be able to do but that
is why they're doing it in two parts instead of
just doing a one 90-minute movie like you would
traditionally see in an animated dc film but this
trailer opens with part two of the story as batman
is talking to falcone and then they intercut
it with him kissing catwoman on the rooftops
during the long halloween story it actually picks
up with bruce wayne dating selena kyle but neither
one of them know that they're batman or catwoman
they don't know their secret identities yet
it's relatively early in batman's career but
it's not batman year one so that is another
similarity to the matt reeves batman movie but
through the story they eventually start to learn
more about each other and then batman starts to
encounter catwoman in their romance as batman
and catwoman stars as well you see harvey dent
still working with gordon and batman to find
the holiday killer who's continued to leave more
clues behind the crime scenes holiday goes around
mostly just killing members of the falcone and
moroni crime families in a bid to pit them against
each other create this civil war inside gotham's
crime family so that they'll take each other down
this is harvey dent with his wife celebrating
this is calendar man in prison again the reason
why calendar man is part of the story is
because all the killings that they're trying
to investigate this serial killer they're looking
for kills people on special holidays something the
calendar man was known for also doing but while
the holiday killer is going around doing this
he's locked up the whole time so they know that
he's not the one that's doing it then they start
teasing more of harvey dent becoming two-faced
flipping his coin making a deal with moroni crime
family to testify in order to get falcone locked
up falcone is the roman that he speaks of in this
scene that's his nickname that they call him and
when he's talking about your parents got into
business with him and think about how many people
ended up dying it ended really badly for everyone
he's talking to bruce wayne without realizing that
he's batman because at the beginning of the story
bruce wayne is good friends with harvey dent which
is why later he tries to help him out as batman
that's also why batman tries to fight to save
two-face even though two-face eventually starts
running around committing all these crimes like
he realizes that harvey dent can be cured of
his insanity but then they follow up showing
you joe chill killing thomas and martha wayne
with the famous pearl scene and young little
kid bruce wayne in crime alley there then you
see scarecrow mad hatter poison ivy what winds
up happening their involvement in the story is
actually only as side characters even though
normally you would think of them as big main
batman villains within the long halloween story
it's mostly the mob characters in the holiday
killer that are the main characters what winds up
happening is that holiday's plan to pit the major
crime families against each other starts working
really well and as things get worse and worse for
falcone he gets backed into our corner he turns
to batman's rogue's gallery of villains for help
that's what his conversation about hiring freaks
is about you never would have done this before
and he's like times are changing so he winds
up getting poison ivy to go after bruce wayne
but as a result of that he inadvertently winds
up taking batman out of the equation temporarily
which is kind of funny because if you sideline
bruce wayne you also kind of sideline batman until
catwoman eventually realizes what's happened and
is able to save him you see joker show up solomon
grundy joker is also just kind of a side character
during this he actually tries to go after holiday
himself eventually because he's so pissed that
he's being upstaged and thinks there's only room
for one maniac in gotham and it's supposed to
be him like how dare you try to steal my thunder
then you see the famous scene of harvey dent
getting the acid thrown in his face starting his
transition to full-blown two-face in his origin
story in the comic this actually happened during
the trial of sal moroney who was coming to testify
against falcone with enough evidence to get him
convicted but during that trial at least in the
comic moroni throws the actual acid and dense face
they might change this a little bit for the movie
but when they're taking him to the hospital harvey
dent he escapes out the back of the ambulance
disappears for a while then resurfaces later
in the story as full-blown two-face this last
scene of two-face when he just rolls in with
all these batman villains is after he's released
the prisoners from arkham asylum based on the
flip of a coin and he says judgment day that's a
reference to him killing falcone to get revenge
for everything after which he turns himself into
gordon and batman because he got everything he
wanted like this is all he was here to do so
you can lock me up now but batman continues to
try and fight for him while he's going around
doing all these things and advocate for him
because he realizes that it's his friend harvey
dent he's sick they can cure him eventually
just to explain the brand new batman series that
they announced so yes matt reeves is doing the
live-action batman spin-off series on hbo from
his batman movie with the characters from the
robber pattinson batman film the other really big
news though is they announced a new batman series
that he's doing with bruce tim so bruce tim from
batman the animated series one of the best series
of all time not just animated series they're
actually collaborating to make a new batman
animated series now they didn't say exactly
what the story is going to be or if it's going
to be inspired by matt reeves batman characters
because if you remember the original batman the
animated series that drew a lot of inspiration
and tone from the michael keaton batman movies
they even used the exact same theme song from his
batman films even though the stories of batman the
animated series were completely different from
the michael keaton batman stories it was just
meant to be a series that was inspired by those
particular batman films so i'm wondering if matt
reeves is kind of doing the same thing with bruce
tim for his live-action batman film hopefully
we'll see episodes next year but it'll be fun
to do videos for that i wish i could have done
videos for the original batman the animated series
maybe if youtube would have been around in the 90s
but if you have any big questions about the long
halloween movie or the live-action batman movie or
what's going on with this new batman the animated
series just leave them in the comments below the
next big thing that's coming up is the marvel loki
episodes coming to disney plus in a couple weeks
i'll be doing videos for all those episodes so
make sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
the first big dc series that's getting that kind
of treatment on hbo max is going to be the john
cena peacemaker series it's going to be a spin-off
from the suicide squad movie that james gunn is
releasing later this year but all the peacemaker
episodes will start dropping in january so we
won't have to wait that long after the movie to
get episodes everyone click here for my brand
new marvel loki trailer video and click here
for my brand new marvel eternals trailer video
and easter eggs thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!